δο να εφορου διαχείρισης και αναπτψυψης το οποίον έχει συμφωνηθεί είναι ένα σχεδε το οποίο
έγινε για να διαφυλάξει τ γιο να προστατεύει τον ακάμα και εναι να δώσει κα
τις κοινότηταις στη δυνατότητα να αποκτήσουν κάποιες έτσι υποδομές και έσοδα ι λόγο ακριβώς του
ακάο στόχος μας δεν είναι επαναλαμβάνων να δηπιουργήσουμε ένανακάμα ο οποίος θα διαφέρει από αυτό
το οποίο είναι ο ακάμας η αγριάδα του η ομορφιά το αυτός ο περιβαλλοντικός της
αυρός για μας πρέπει να διαφιλακεί καυ είναι μετούν των τρόπο που προσεγκίζουμε την την
επιστροφή μας στο παιδίον κί τις σκεφτικές όταν υπαν ότις το πρόγραμμα σου πριμερικές μέρες
θα πήγαινες με το πριγκηπικό ζευγάρι να δουν πάρα το καλιέργεις ήταν κάτι το οποίον
ξεγίνισε πάραπολους μήνες πριν το κάνουμε μαζί με την πρις βια της της ολλανδίας δεν
ήταν καθόλου τιχοδηλαδή όταν ήρθε νο πρέσβις τοσυζητήοσαμε πώς θα κάνουμε του τη ν επίσκεψη
ηείχαν ισηγηθεί των απάμε ακριβώς να να δούμε τις πατατοκαλιέρχες πτου να δούμε γεοργούς που
χρησιμοοποιούν των ολλαντικόσπορ το θεόρε α ξέρε την κίνηδεα και πραγματικά το χάρι κατιοήδητου εχαρικαν
πάραπολύ ασμύτια το χαρικο φτάξει καινο που που εσσημαντικών κρατο έσι πάντω ικώνα που τουτην
ούλη τητην επίσκεψη ήταν την κυρία να αναστασία τη μάμα του γιου του γιώργου ενός
που του γεοργού που επιάμενι στο στο χράφιν του η οποία κάθετουν έτσι στη λίο
μακριά για παρακολφοή τσι με καμάρι το γιο της σε λό κοίταξε ένα για πρώτηφορά
ένας βασιλικά του μια βασίλιση